Bro, what is happening in this community? Are they that oblivious
to what's going on? Am I like, are they talking about Pixie here?
Destiny is panicking after seemingly losing his all of his income
and being outed publicly for a minor in the middle of a legal
battle he appears to be losing. What are you talking about? This
is like, wait, oh, is this new? Destiny is now having a meltdown
in DG chat because spoiled white girl Pixie Love committed the
crime of hiring an experts forensic guy to verify that Bonerelli
had been tampering with and falsifying evidence submitted to
the court. Wait, what the [__] is this, dude? I'm
going to lose it. It cannot be this Mimi for court. Plaintiff
has preceded 3,000 documents or produced 3,000 documents. This
piece of sent me every single Discord message in a separate text
file and like 80% of what she provided were just messages from
our group chat. I'm so annoyed. Like this whole thing is a giant
joke to her. It's all memes and sh they pay some stupid experts
forensics guy to say my logs are tampered with and they're comparing
them to Solo's logs who we can't depose, who isn't part of the
case. How can I even speak for any of this [__] Actually,
so [__] r It's actually so rworded, Destiny. That
50k is going a long way compared to whatever you spent. She's
not using that 50k. Her parents are loaded and are covering this
100%. It's so annoying that I've spent so many days and weeks
of my time compiling stuff. She hasn't turned over anything and
just frolicking around like nothing is even happening and they're
just playing games the whole time. Destiny, what is Jane Do's
incentive for dragging this case out with this memes this long?
Is it just to burn your
Dude, these guys are I mean, his cult is so stupid. Like, they
just don't understand like that there is a wronged party here.
And of course, the wronged party is going to
uh is is going to understandably
follow through. According to Pixie's new legal filing, it has
been definitively determined that Destiny was sending material
to a minor and was in possession of of that same minor. Lock
him up. I mean, yeah, that's um what is this? In in Pixie's
opposition to Destiny's motion to dismiss her legal team reveals
that Rose, the then underage child Destiny was exchanging with,
has been issued a subpoena and is sent to be deposed. After finally
ascertaining Rose's legal identity, plaintiff has obtained evidence
that Rose's date of birth is October 30th, 2004. Thus, when Bonnel
was exchanging content with Rose between March of 2022 and until
October 30th, 2022, Rose was a minor. See exhibit B here too.
Redacted official certification of the Department of Motor Vehicles
driving record. Well, yeah. I the the fact that he's like complaining
about this when uh this is an active court case
where obviously the the party that was um victimized is going
to do everything they can to put together a a coherent
case that you know like what do you mean destiny? Jane does incentive
or drag in this case. Super boy to attack my reputation or waste
my money since she has no reputation and never will. Hers doesn't
matter. And since her parents are apparently loaded, it's not
her money, so she doesn't care. Do you know why we she wants
to bring you down so bad? It feels so out of the blue. You were
friends before, bro. What is happening in this community? Are
they that oblivious to what's going on? Am I like, are they talking
about Pixie here? Who's suing him for what? I don't know this
clown's news, dude. I don't even know where to begin. Okay. Jesus
Christ. Destiny procured
child abuse material from a minor 100%. This is like now officially
in the court uh documents. Okay. And in the process of procuring
child abuse material from a minor, he I don't know why he did
this, but sent that minor a bunch of videos of him having sometimes
consensual
consensually recorded sex acts with other people and sometimes
unconsensually recorded sex acts with other people. He had compiled
like this this entire library of content that he sent to a minor
that he was trying to okay and then somehow that minor or an
associate or someone leaked all of those videos and then people
basically were like what the are you know these are people these
are people that you consider orbiters like people that were members
of his community girls that were content creators within his
orbit. orbit of influence. Girls that were dating other content
creators who were also orbiters of his. And
they were obviously
very frustrated with the reality when they found out that he
was just sending their tapes to random people that he was trying
to. So, one of the victims
actually sought damages and sued him for releasing the revenge
of them having this is that court case. And then there were other
victims that I think uh also joined in on the court case as well.
There was also another person that found out that she was actually
unconsensually recorded while having sex
with this person.
there's a a a criminal uh charge potentially as well. And this
has just been like an ongoing this has been an ongoing legal
battle for him in the state of Florida.
And in the process
of this ongoing legal battle, he went and and
hired
the same law firm that actually defended Prince Andrews. But
the problem is he's so he's such a dick that he thinks he can
like debate lord his way out of this. Also worth mentioning that
the reason nobody goes after him is because they fear his community.
Yeah. But in the process of all this stuff happening, he literally
he literally went to one of the worst communities of doxers and
egged them on flexing about how they would never find the information
of this minor.
Okay? And he even revealed details about said minor. So, of course,
that community of doctors found the information of said minor
and confirmed that she was a minor at the time. Like, if you
have an ongoing legal battle, it's probably better for you to
shut the up. You know what I mean? Especially because
only a month ago or two months ago, not shutting the up caused
people to go and find the identity of this person and confirm
that she was a minor when you were d when you were getting from
them. Destiny, how much longer do you think it goes on for? No
clue. It looks like they want to try and make it survive to trial,
but I have no idea why. She has absolutely nothing. Do you think
he's going to pull out the ethical CP debate in court? I don't
know, but some somewhere along the the the way somewhere along
Wait, what? We don't have to cover this every week. Okay, I'm
going to start banning. I haven't talked about this in months.
What are you talking about? And the only reason why I brought
this up is because of chatter because JD Vance is seemingly trying
to go after Destiny on some free speech which I said was inappropriate
and unacceptable. And then someone said, "Oh, have you seen this?"
and revealed to me that there is new details in this court case.
I hate when go you talk about this every week. I don't I hate
when dumb say like that. As a matter of fact, the only reason
why I had to describe the details of this court case is because
chatters were like, "I don't know who the this person is or I
don't know what the this person has done, evidence to the reality
that I don't actually cover this [__] that much for
understandable reasons. There are far more consequential things
happening in the world." What? Anyway, his community and orbit
have been one massive knot of reality show style interpersonal
drama for like a decade and likely so many people had their lives
affected or ruined by the scene. More people need to know. I
know. I know. But yeah, it seems like uh it seems like he's just
more invested in uh
eating whatever damages that come if this goes to court or I
mean it is in court already, but it seems like he's just invested
in eating whatever damages happen, knowing full well that it's
going to happen, but in the process like retaining some uh you
know, retaining whichever
uh whichever percentage of the cult that he can maintain. And
that's why he's just like steadily victim blaming and and and
talking about how um this law this lawsuit is actually
for uh purely selfish reasons and that this person has no um
reason to to do such a thing. Like the the smart thing to do
in this situation would be to just shut the up, you know, let
your lawyers do the talking. But he's obviously not doing that
because he thinks, well, whichever way the court case goes, it
doesn't really matter. Yeah, sure. I eat a lot of damages, but
like I need to retain a sizable chunk of my audience that's like
Everything he says gets added to Discovery probably. Yeah, I
I do genuinely think his his um I mean he will always lead to
his own downfall. That that much is that much was clear to me.
But um I I do think he fancies himself to be uh this brilliant
person. Like he he fancies himself to be like a like a genuine
unique mind like the the brain that that no one has with a brain
that no one has ever seen before. Like he's smarter than his
lawyers. He's smarter than everybody else. And that he can basically
debate himself out of any corner
including including this. Very strange special boy syndrome.
He tried to take the Elsat on stream and crashed out Lau. Oh
yeah, I remember that cuz he was uh he was uh trying to dunk
on a lawyer friend of mine actually. What if this hits national
news going to be used to persecute the left? Unfortunately, it's
a W for us and the victim and the victims, but it's a massive
L overall I fear. Wait, what? No. What are you talking about?
What? A W for the Wait, I'm confused. Are you talking about There's
two separate incidents here. If you're talking about Pixie's
case against Destiny, that's entirely separate. If you're talking
about JD Vance
uh uh trying to prosecute Destiny for speech, then those are
two separate incidents. One is completely inappropriate and also
unconstitutional.
The other is
within the confines of the law and has nothing to do with the
left at all. It's just it's just a a victim being able to successfully
sue someone who distribute
distributed
material of them. The the [__] does that have to
do with the left? They're separate, but that won't stop them
from using them to smear the entire left. It doesn't help that
people close to the party still with them on America. UN America
is not close to the party.
The are you guys talking about? You need to re you need to literally
remove yourself from whatever bubble that you exist in.
No one. Like,
dude, as much as I [__] on the Democratic Party,
I would go so far as to say I'm closer to the Democratic Party,
both in the eyes of the general public and also uh in the eyes
of the Democratic party than someone like Destiny is. The [__]
do you mean? It doesn't matter if they try to be like, "Oh, this
this liberal debater uh turned out to be a pest is going to be
make national news or something like that's utterly irrelevant
in the grand scheme of things." What What are you guys talking
about? What is happening with my first mic arm? Someone said
that's ad homonym. What? Yeah, I think you guys have um have
developed this like
outsized
uh like you for one reason or another. Maybe you were former
Destiny fans, maybe you're still currently Destiny fans,
but um you have you have believed in this like totally false
notion that he just like represents a wing of the Democrat party
or something. He does not. He is um not all that relevant in
the grand scheme of things. No. And UN America is like a a totally
random group that most likely did a lot of reputational damage
uh to whatever ambition, whatever ambitious goals that they had
uh by associating early on with someone like Destiny. Anyway,
let's get back